do you think in order to solve
intelligence we also need to solve
consciousness along the way do you think
agi systems need to have consciousness
in order to
be
truly intelligent yeah we thought about
this a lot actually and um i think that
my guess is that consciousness and
intelligence are double dissociable so
you can have one without the other both
ways and i think you can see that with
consciousness in that i think some
animals
and pets if you have a pet dog or
something like that you can see some of
the higher animals and dolphins things
like that are uh have self-awareness and
uh very sociable um seem to dream um you
know those kinds of a lot of the traits
one would regard as being kind of
conscious and self-aware um and but yet
they're not that smart right uh so
they're not that intelligent by by say
iq standards or something like that yeah
it's also possible that our
understanding of intelligence is flawed
like putting an iq to it sure maybe the
thing that a dog can do
is actually gone very far along the path
of intelligence and we humans are just
able to play chess and maybe write poems
right but if we go back to the idea of
agi and general intelligence you know
dogs are very specialized right most
animals are pretty specialized they can
be amazing at what they do but they're
like kind of elite sports sports people
or something right so they do one thing
extremely well because their entire
brain is is optimized they have somehow
convinced the entirety of the human
population to feed them and service them
so in some way they're controlling yes
exactly well we co-evolved to some crazy
degree right uh including the the way
the dogs you know even even wag their
tails and twitch their noses right we
find we're finding inexorably cute yeah
but i think um you can also see
intelligence on the other side so
systems like artificial systems that are
amazingly
smart at certain things like maybe
playing go and chess and other things
but they don't feel at all in any shape
or form conscious in the way that you
know you do to me or i do to you and um
and i think actually
building ai is uh these intelligent
constructs uh is one of the best ways to
explore the mystery of consciousness to
break it down because um we're gonna
have devices that are uh pretty smart at
certain things or capable of certain
things but potentially won't have any
semblance of self-awareness or other
things and in fact i would advocate if
there's a choice building systems in the
first place ai systems that are not
conscious to begin with are just tools
until we understand them better
and the capabilities better
you